Concerny metastasis of cancer to the lungs.
So first as breast cancer metastasis
and lung liver cancer, colon cancer metastasis
to the lungs, I've heard that breathing in alkaline water
could help alkalize or destroy the tumors in the lungs.
Do you have any suggestions about how to do this?
Yeah, don't, don't do that.
You breathe in alkaline water, you'll drown.
So that's not a good thing to do.
It's not the alkalinity that is going to kill the cancer
to the lungs, the cancer in the lungs.
I would suggest hydrogen peroxide
and use the hydrogen peroxide protocol
that is on the whole page of the member site
and use nebulized hydrogen peroxide.
If you nebulized alkaline water,
you're not getting the alkalinity from the water.
So I would not do that.
You can't breathe in water, you will drown.
So you can't nebulize things,
you could nebulize a liquid corniceps.
But I don't know how much corniceps
you're getting through a nebulizer.
I think your best chance is to try to kill directly
as nebulized hydrogen peroxide.
Nebulizer peroxide is an oxidizing agent.
You could get it to the cancer directly,
you could kill the cancer.
So that would be the best route, not alkaline water.